[Music]
please don't get involved
what is up fam it is monday morning
july 11th
it is toasty out here kids
we're in the summer so it's pretty hot
everywhere
shout out to global warming just kidding
i don't know how i feel about that
this outfit is so goddamn summer
if summer was a mascot you're looking at
him
it's thick boy summer season and that's
how we dress
no crocs
no goddamn crocs
look at my instagram uh my heart was
broken because my kid you know kids all
those dads out there you have kiddos you
can play this chicken go ahead i'll tell
you something that's breaking my heart
maybe having other dads out there so i
told my kiddo
who's six
i said dude your shoes are a nightmare
you need some new kicks i'm a sneaker
head so i said you can get whatever pair
of shoes you want reasonable you know
you're not getting yeezy red october but
you know whatever foot locker has
and uh the new trend
for kids these
days rocks
styrofoam frogs tie-dye styrofoam
both of them
any shoe in the world
pick this [ __ ] as a sneaker head you
know how that makes me feel as a goddamn
sneaker hat they picked this [ __ ]
that lady's not getting here she's like
are you shooting a video it's not good
at all
and also grown men out there that wear
crocs um don't know you know don't
mm-hmm
i don't get the the whole croc
the croc hype i know they're comfy man
sandals are comfy too doesn't mean you
should have your toes your toenails with
toe jam out in public in restaurants and
[ __ ] on planes
what are we doing how did we get to this
point
and my kid
dude
he's at jordan once he had yeezys his
buddy game yeezys you know they're kids
so they absolutely destroy them so they
go through them and i don't know
dude after a month they they're just
destroyed you know kids
they don't give a [ __ ]
and then i was like oh dude we need to
take you to the mall you get some new
sneakers because i can't have you
looking like you know a bum right now
let's get sneakers and then he's begging
for crocs and i was like dude let's not
he and he asked like a few weeks before
about crocs and i just ignored it that's
not happening
and then he just won't pipe down about
crocs and of course his little brother
who's two and his older brothers his
hair was like yeah crocs i'm like god
damn it guys
so i just rock these crocs dude
and they want to do whatever they want
to play basketball in them i'm like dude
you're playing basketball and freaking
sandals all they are sand their
styrofoam sandals with color but they
their toes are closed now here i have a
history with crocs too everyone's like
don't knock it to you try it dude you
should try them out stop it i've tried
them your boy has tried them check this
out crocs
i don't know what the connection is but
the creative crocs has i think either
graduate from music university colorado
or has some ties to the university of
colorado
so
when i this i graduated in
college 2006 so in 2004
2004 i think i was a sophomore
they gave the entire football team the
first crocs ever
and my friend gary moore shout out to
gary moore who was six eight four
hundred pounds at least uh he had such a
big foot they're like just put them in
the dryer so they they they [ __ ] get
warm and then put your foot in them and
mold to your foot that's what you're
dealing with here
so you're dealing with so i've had
cracks i warm people warm all during the
the camp you know what i'm saying
because we're in camp you're switching
from cleats and all that stuff dude
check that out june 20 crocs move
headquarters to niwa colorado nywot is
30 minutes from boulder and they're
originally in broomfield which is
probably 10 minutes from boulder croc
founder uh produced uh
quebec developed
developed as a boating shoe that makes
sense for a lot of boating shoes okay
yeah they have some type well apparently
the ties they're up the street from
university cholera so they like ran a
test on our football team they gave us
like 200 pairs of croc so everybody's
wearing them
nobody got laid
we've ran the trial
we've we've we i've done the the work
we've ran i'm telling you guys i'm not
this just isn't my opinion i'm telling
you we're like what's going on man last
year we're having such a good year with
the ladies and some guys now we got the
crocs on nobody's getting action
it took us a little while to realize oh
crocs don't make the dudes hard and
don't make the girls come to the yard
like look at that get out of my face
dude kind of ruins the suit yeah the
ruins the suit
it's just i it's
it's you know what it is it's laziness
yeah look you got shia labeouf wearing
them that makes sense bieber's wearing
them but listen these guys are wearing
them because it's a hypebeast thing it's
what's it like none of them look cool
no one looks dope in these pictures
you're like ugh
have a little pride you know i mean
open-toed sandals at the airport is just
disgusting my son has basically those
whatever uh homeboy is wearing that
that's yeah
they're tied oh my god dude
i'll straight up tell them but you can't
wear those out of the house dude you
can't do it i wonder where i'm damn like
not happening you're gonna be playing
basketball and reason summer camps like
dude you don't want to wear crocs
and you're saying they're they're
attaching that stuff right all that
stuff to them the kids
yeah like magnets oh they're magnets and
they're not magnets they go into little
holes but they're basically fridge
magnets
there's like pokemon ones like what
you know look at that that's the so
there's just sand crouches like all
right we'll make sandals too for all the
people out there so you like customize
them get pokemon and whatever
i dude it's not happening and all the
i'm telling you you guys that blew up my
instagram going don't knock it till you
try it i've tried it i was the first one
i was the first one
oh my god one of them has a heel on it
and what those are well that was just
just absolutely ridiculous right yeah i
i mean as a sneaker it breaks my heart
man you will never catch me in those
again you want to wear them at home it's
comfy it's a house shoe
more power to you you want to rock some
uggs tom brady wears hugs i get it
but when you you can't
leave the house in crocs or uggs
can't i don't give a [ __ ] if post
malone's rocking them whatever you can't
do it
shout out to crocs though
shout out to crockies
um
yeah let's get to it man uh we got some
fights this weekend we got a food truck
this week
let's see but we're filming one but we
got one in the can we got the marvin
victoria food truck i think is this week
that's a fun one it's the most expensive
food truck in the history of food trucks
um pizza was good
pizza was good
solid
solid
salt it's it's like we thought it was
like authentic like italian that's why i
did it for marvin because he's like i'll
drive down dude but i need pizza because
i'm about to go into camp
i'm like dude i'm gonna get you the
truck for pizza it's italian a super
italian name i sent him the name he's
like dude that's actually italian yeah
most most americans spell it wrong i'm
trying to do this truck you've never
seen anything like it come on down
he comes down
or yet there's two mexicans making the
pizza
now listen i'm not saying that mexicans
can't make pizza i'm just saying we
thought it was a fully
authentic italian truck we thought
italians owned it and i go oh are you
guys you know sometimes tough to tell
but you guys like nah man mexican and uh
martin's like oh um okay and i was like
yeah this is a bad side and i go yeah
but the owner's attack right goes no no
mexican dude too
i looked down i'm so sorry dude but he
actually enjoyed the pizza
he's a fun one man and listen i i've
never met him before such a good dude
probably
style wise top five the most stylish
guys we've had on the show dressed
[ __ ] fantastic has a crazy story
he's just a good dude really really good
dude smart dude smart dude because he
always uh
his biggest i think super power what
makes him an outlier amongst you know
those top five guys
is he's constantly obsessed with getting
better nothing's good enough so he's
always
super highly critical of himself and
wants to work on what is going to get
him better whether he you know he has a
you know flawless performance something
like that it doesn't matter he's finding
something to work on and you can you'll
see the theme throughout the food truck
it's all about him getting better it's
always him getting better so it's
inspiring man great dude really really
good dude
really really good dude um but you had
some fights this weekend
get some fights this weekend fight night
your boy watched from the prelims to the
main event
and uh good card for a free cartoon
you're not mad at it dude no not at all
why would you be dude why would you be
mad at this card um
it was a good one
that jamie uh malarkey michael john
johnson who did you have jen johnson
yeah two to one i had johnson uh so the
first round they both knocked each other
down second round you give to malarkey
right and then third round you give to
johnson so i probably give the first and
third to johnson
it seemed like the crowd agreed to now
i'm i'm a malarkey fan i think you know
johnson's records whatever 20 19 or
something that's you know so
here's that salty veteran record but um
you know
it's probably as far as him like
taking a run for the title those days
probably passed them um you know
malarkey has a lot of hope in them so
it's a bummer because you know i do
think johnson lost what's funny is when
they were uh going to judges decisions
um
johnson kept going don't [ __ ] me don't
you [ __ ] me you know he's been around so
long he's not [ __ ] before
kind of got [ __ ] here mary he's also
the guy which is he's had some
phenomenal fights remember he's from the
ultimate fighter and all that [ __ ] but
he's had some great fights in his career
explosive just a good solid dude him
rashad evans are really close
remember a lot of times you'll see even
the mma experts will say uh
he's the one guy that uh
wobbled
khabib remember we [ __ ]
mean could be was like cool story dude
my head hurts i'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of you remember that's when he was
like whooping his ass talking to dana
he's like what are you doing man you
gotta give up
so he's lost one two three four
five i was last six
hm
he got five tonight though they're not
going to cut a guy a fight of the night
and it's michael johnson so you know
he's a name they're not going to cut him
loses his necks when he's out i bet
yeah you know
fun always fun to watch but jim malarkey
i he i felt like he could have made it
easier on himself i felt like he had
more tools to win his his range was good
and then he just kind of played the game
you know yeah fighter in that game yeah
yep yep chase sherman got it done threw
like a 30 punch combo that was so common
a lot better man dude chase sherman came
to reign training center uh to spar with
me and metreon because mitrione used to
fly down and train with us
and we didn't know who he was he's this
tall dude i think he played football
before and he just came in a huge head
and i remember matt was like just got
done sparring want to go with him and
then i watched him matt going
it was tough i was like oh [ __ ] this kid
is tough man really tough even i was
like who the [ __ ] is that man i don't
know and he was just trying to get you
know he's just getting started in it but
he's [ __ ] tough man uh go up chin
let's see born raise mississippi
uh shrimp play football
doesn't matter dilbert all right
uh he could deal with a sport on a
scholarship to jones junior college
for transferring to delta state
delta state i'm pretty sure is a black
school
the team reached the division two
national championship in 2001 he's the
offensive tackle he used to be a big boy
sherman earned a bachelor's degree in
sports management excited science
shouldn't reveal they graduated from the
fire academy eligible to work as a
firefighter oh damn i see you dog
uh he's fun to watch he's really fun to
watch
he threw like a 30 piece combo god dawg
he lost four before that yeah the ufc is
giving guys some chances man i think
they let him go and then brought him
back for some reason
for one of the fights i don't think for
this one but it might have been for this
that was good well this is his second
stand in the ufc because he was in the
fc he lost three in a row they let him
go and fought in florida in ireland
fights
and then got back
and then
um he won his first one back
and then he's lost four in a row
and then they're like you know what dude
let's give you one more good performance
of the night got four in a row
you sheesh
got that yeah that ufc record is tough
daddy because
he lost his
last oh my you yes he is tough
so he went he lost he went one um so he
went two and
two and five
in his first stint and then now he's two
and four
you know so he's four and nine overall
in the ufc and has a job man because he
is exciting there's not a ton of
heavyweights but man i'm surprised they
ain't coming after that fourth loss man
i kind of feel like they let him go but
then they brought him back for service i
don't remember exactly though
interesting yeah either way entertaining
fight yeah super entertaining fight
games fighting was not keto
it's just being friendly uh that's said
nerga medov
monster isn't it and he thought douglas
silva de andre uh that douglas silva has
nine thousand fights and he's only lost
like two so and he's a v you know i
think he's like 37. um
he's a beast dude he's a he's a super
beast he beat marlon vera he you know
he's a tough [ __ ] character
but he uh
he made the fight fun
i'm super high on uh said super high in
him in a bent weight division super
highnum
cardio to me in that third round seems
to be an issue because
originally you know he's been starch and
dudes starching freaking dudes uh if you
look at so his last two fights uh so
he lost one a yes a decision but so he
throws
90 spending backfist throughout the
fight yeah like that's his thing
spinning back fist um you've never seen
someone throw more spinning backfist
it's exciting but it's also
throw less though you know so people are
surprised
because he got the knockout uh in 2019
against ricardo ramos phenomenal
knockout
loses next one and then his next two
fights
the longest fight is 51 seconds he's
destroying dudes destroying cody stamen
guillotine choke destroying him here's
what's interesting about him is because
his name is
megan madoff we all associate that with
dagestani wrestling
this dude's striking is his thing i i
don't know what his [ __ ] i know
international master of sport that's
what all those days standing guys have
but his strike his cakes are filthy
his boxing to me doesn't seem to
exactly be there but his [ __ ]
footwork his kicks um his takedown
defense is really good
but you assume he's just going to
grapple somebody because his last name
right now is nurmega madoff is that the
same as like being from brazil and being
called silva like everyone's silva
everyone mexico's garcia you know what
i'm saying
let's say or everyone america's robinson
you feel me is that the same you know
what i'm saying
it's a common name right yeah
what's up fam let's take a little break
from the shop show here because we got
to keep these house lights on studio
lights not my house i don't record for
my house that'd be weird uh before we
get into this little ad read i'm in fort
wayne indiana this thursday friday
saturday fort wayne come on out can't
wait tickets at thickboy.com then next
week i'm in san diego california july
21st the 23rd is san diego california at
the laugh factory in the heart of san
diego come get you some before wayne
you're up this week thursday friday
saturday
listen man how well would you take care
of your car if you had to keep the same
one your entire life what would you do
hopefully you change the oil you take
care of it make sure it's function right
well guess what that's how your brain
works yep so why don't we treat it that
way you gotta keep your mental health
good man yep this is a word from my
sponsor better help i swear by these
guys your boy use a therapist and better
help online therapy listen they offer it
for video phone even live chat online
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy in person can get
really expensive but better help dude
you get for a fraction of the price they
actually help you it's not your friends
giving you advice and that stuff we're
talking about licensed professionals
better help online therapy is
powerful it's freaking the way you take
control of your life it gets you on
track it's fantastic all right
it's much more affordable like i told
you guys in person you can be matched
with a therapist under 48 hours and the
listeners and viewers of the shop show
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
that's better
h help dot com shop
it's a man from cringing at the gas pump
to get an eye popping check at your
favorite restaurant inflation is hitting
this all where it hurts and it hurts
that's why i started using upside upside
is an incredible app for anyone who buys
gas groceries or dines out
for anyone that just lives normal right
you want to buy stuff gas groceries
eating out with your friends with every
purchase your boy is earning cash back
thanks to upside you're like man this is
too good to be true it actually works
man upside is a no-brainer all right you
get cash back for the things you're
gonna do anyway all right to get started
download the free upside app in the app
store or google play use the promo code
shop s-c-h-a-b get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more all right it's a cup of
uh
your frappuccino at a starbucks customer
and that you getting cash back dude next
claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with a credit or
debit card and you get paid with the app
man in comparison to credit card rewards
or loyalty programs you can earn three
times more cash back with upside yep
it's better than those you can cash out
anytime to your bank account paypal or
egift card for amazon other brands
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star rating
on the app store it's good guys and
right now we need it with inflation
download the free upside app and use
promo code shop
s-h-a-b to get five dollars more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that's five dollars more
cash back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code
yeah heavy like the ground extreme
associated with
one of the best if not the best ever do
it and all he does is grapple you're
gonna assume he's a grappler goddamn
this dude can he's so exciting to watch
man he's so fun
what's interesting about him too he's
his haircut doesn't move
here does not move they have the
thickest hair it i i think it's thick
and my girl's like well he probably cuts
it that way i'm like no [ __ ] he woke up
like that he's here he's dagging stains
here just it's thick and just
it's like uh and his corner man too in
his hair it's like uh my sons play with
these lego pieces and yeah
clip the hair on that's what that is it
doesn't move he'll be in a guillotine
no issues
if there's a slight breeze in there if
they see kicks on my hair gets [ __ ] up
i have to take care but not compared to
dagestanian thick
his hair does not move the entire fight
flawless hair if that's your style
flawless hair
thing with dagger standings um but i was
thinking after i find my all right he
starts two dudes he beat this veteran
and uh douglas silva de'andre they're
gonna give him a big name
and i was like he after watching the
first round like oh first round really
second round i think he lost but um
first round i was like get students
ready for top 15.
this cardio was an issue in that third
round which is alarming
cardio was an issue he's laying down
gave up you know went for a knee bar
and then i thought they were off on the
co-main event
it's too obviously they're giving it to
two guys who were uh dan white contender
series guys
um
dude petrosian
hopefully you can find this reference
chin i've been oh thank god i remembered
armin petrosian he's from uh didn't
white contestants
280 i think i'm right on this if my
childhood memory serves me 280 he looks
like the muay thai specialist in
bloodsport bring him up dude and he's
the one who trades uh body kicks with
jean-claude van damme they're the same
guy
i hope my memory serves me right
let's see
paco
i don't know his name
yes he does sing guy
dude
what's up daddy
that's a damn good is that a weird
[ __ ] callback
we call that a deep callback
don't the chin am i off on this no
you're good they're the same guy that's
your talent that's your gift it's a
shitty gift
dude they're the exact same
hopefully people can see this they're
the exact same [ __ ] guy
dude and that's strange dude
oh they go it's the muay thai guy from
bloodsport
you know him because he's like romero
class like come on he's kicking come on
come on they just knock somebody like
spins greatest move of all time the same
guy uh
i would assume the actor
in bloodsport has better takedown
defense
because armin it's petrosian
zero wrestling zero wrestling or
grappling capabilities it was insane
it's weird they put them as a co-main
event
i thought it was strange
i know there's a bit of hype there
because the the contenders are yeah the
dana white contender series but how
sedner met off isn't the co-main event
was weird to me and then the main event
which in my head was getting late and
i'm on season five of bates motel um i
have like three shows left i'm like
please don't go to decision this is
gonna wait too long because you you you
had out of s what would we have two four
out of six fights you had four decisions
so i was like come on man let's
you know come on fuzzies let's get down
or do sanjos here's my thing about dos
anjos um i never pick against them i've
said this a million times i think the
team posted a clip of this when i was
fighting uh big nog in brazil when your
americans fight in a brazilian they all
hate you and they're trying to poison
your food uh hafio dos sanchos when i go
out there to train and promote the fight
i could rely on him every time to pick
me up in his little honda civic and take
me around and show me where to get food
where it's safe the best food i went
with him drop his kid off one time he'd
tell me where to hike he's the nicest
[ __ ] guy in the world so i will never
pick against them ever ever ever super
biased
the physique is a tough fight for him
fazeeb was tough fight for him
dude and people are like oh if favielle
can get them down it's game over for
physique you know because stamp
specialist was he from uh azure band
i'll look it up right now i think he's
the first fighter ever from uh
azerbaijan
kazakhstan
he's a blue belt
yeah he would have some real problems so
he's really from kazakhstan
kazakhstan kazakhstan to an azerbaijani
father and a russian mother so that's
where you got the izer barzoni all sorts
of [ __ ] going on there the citizen of
kyrgyzstan oh
yeah he's a problem he's striking so fun
to watch yeah dude but as a blue belt
and in my head i'm like
dos angel's won two since he's gone down
to lightweight
and dos angels he is the
[Music]
trying to think who has the toughest
schedule in football college football
there's some you know strength of
schedule for dos angels is the toughest
of all time when he went to welterweight
you look at who he's fought you look at
um lightweight who he's fought there's
no one's had a a tougher
schedule of opponents ever in the
history of the ufc than dos anjos ever
because in the height of him fighting at
uh lightweight he was fighting the
tip of the spear dude
name anybody in lightweight name anybody
uh 170 he's fought him in their prime
dude i mean look at his [ __ ] look at
that dude look at that freaking
cerrone in his heyday uh evan dunham
don't don't y'all must have forgot evan
dunn was a [ __ ] savage
khabib
uh benson henderson that's how you won
the belt
nate diaz anthony perez cerrone again
eddie alvarez tony ferguson
safidine you almost forgot about him as
well
neil magni robbie lawler colby covington
kamar usman kevin lee leon edwards
michael chieza paul felder
monsino and then faziv
no one has a tougher strength schedule
of all time in the ufc the guy is a
[ __ ] bonafide first ballot hall of
fame legend
so he lives in brazil he says that's
where he needs to stay focused and he
wants to make another run at the title
so this was a fork in the road for both
these gentlemen for physique right he's
on a six fight winning streak he's you
know uh he's coming off some some big
wins
um
and you you want to
you want to invest in him you know his
fight with brad riddell even though they
were sparring partners that was the fun
one but you want to invest him but he
hasn't gotten over the hump so when they
give you a guy in dos angelo's former
champion toughest schedule of all time
legend
to be honest should be a bad matchup for
him if you can get him down your blue
belt dos angelo's world-class jiu jitsu
so and he's fought the who's who so
you're trying to figure out where fazeev
is and if you can actually invest in him
if he was a stock that's what the ufc is
trying to do here that's why they made
him a main event
and he passed the test man i didn't
realize how [ __ ] good his wrestling
is i thought jos angelos would get him
down
dos angelo's got him down once i think
he shot i don't know 16 times got him
down once he has the best takedown
defense
outside of kamar usm in the ufc
it's like 95 percent take down defense
accuracy kamaru swin is 100
which is why he's pound-for-pound guy
right now um but dos angelo's got in
deep on one and dude he wizard [ __ ]
threw him down yeah
tough dude tough tough tough now let me
ask you this guys
for the fans out there
how would fazeev do against uh a
makachev
you know
[Music]
how good is his anti-wrestling
and if he's a blue belt on the on the
ground if you get taken down by makchev
blue belt ain't gonna cut it
a black belt would have a hard time with
monk jeff and when you look at you know
the other champion charles oliveira
[Music]
there's no champ right now but let's be
honest he's the champ he missed wait i
get it they [ __ ] with the scales whole
weird thing uh with charles oliveira if
you're bluebell on the ground see i
don't think charles oliver could get him
down well charles can get some guys down
okay get you down you can get him down
you know fezziv looks super strong
though when he was he looks strong and
his tan
man just well grounded yeah no
issues
just
bronze yeah very sexy amish you know
so for ziv is like what do you do next
so los angeles rank what seven let me
see the lightweight rankings chin fazeev
is seven now i would assume
it's over here
ah there he is
so he's gonna jump uh dos anjos
gamrat would be a fun fight
fazeev if you just fought seven do you
fight the narrate guy
because you're he's not getting oliver
he's not getting poor he's not getting
gates he's not getting machete he's not
getting chandler
daryush physique could be fun
again another tough tough matchup
because darius can
you know high level black belt on the
ground yeah my the only knock on fazeeva
is achilles heel if he's actually just a
blue belt on the ground
charles oliver charles oliveira
you know greatest submission artists
we've had statistically as far as uh
submission bonuses and finishes justin
poiret high level black belt
gaijin would be the best fight for him
if for him to get to the title uh the
number one guy he needs to beat and to
kind of jump the queue and get his name
in the title shot be justin gaichy
justin doesn't wrestle i'd say just
probably
blue belt on the ground that's being
generous you know he doesn't really do
it so
justin gage is fancies himself a striker
now doesn't really use his wrestling and
is justin gaichi going to go pound for
pound with him with what kicks
okay enjoy that with fazeev
he definitely has a power advantage but
that's a phenomenal fight now he
a lot of people are saying you know
physique and uh
gaichi but the thing about that is
uh geichi i think he's getting no
surgery yeah and
my friend crystalia just got no surgery
and he's like oh i'm only out a day i'm
like you're out of your [ __ ] mind
because i did it and it takes forever
it's one of the worst surgeries you can
have takes forever
so if justin's going uh he's undergoing
no surgery that physique fighting ain't
happening for a hot second end of the
year he said
he said he's gonna do at the end of the
year no but by the time his nose will be
recovered by the end oh in july yeah
he's fighting november december by the
time that nose is
proper
and after that surgery your nose
actually gets tougher to break
so early next year end of the year this
year or early next year
yeah i'm telling you it's a hot second
if you get that nose surgery but
physique
for physique by far the best matchup in
the top three for him to jump the cue
you know
you give me those other guys i mentioned
he could get a little dicey for him
a physique fan though terrible call out
caught field nadal the tennis player
busy wings like yeah no that's uh that's
cool that's in tennis but uh in the
lightweight ufc division anybody you
just kept calling off
he just he refused to call people out
kind of respect it he has fun with it
some guys are because that's ufc's thing
now right like all the so so you guys
know all the people that go in the ring
bisbee rogan
um anak dc they all have earpieces in
and they were a producer going uh ask
him who's next push him on who he wants
next that's like their thing now they
put the pressure on these guys yeah i
mean he did in the post post fight
conference say he wanted gaichi but
that's like a really tough call-out
i mean i could see him doing it for sure
i see him doing it yeah for sure but
it's just it's
i and i don't think it's far-fetched i
mean coming off all those wins you know
and it's a [ __ ] phenomenal [ __ ] fight
that's fine tonight written all
over it dude
but you know if if uh
gaitre's gonna get this no surgery he's
out so
he's not gonna wait to what [ __ ] next
year january february 2023 there's no
way cfa has to get rolling
now
the smart thing to do if you're physical
is weight
100 percent
because they give you one of these other
boys and they get you down like oliveira
and have no but oliveira poury machachev
who sure as [ __ ] don't want chandler can
wrestle his ass off dare you shouldn't
be a tough one for you
you know
[Music]
yeah there's championship hopes there i
just it's tough dude it's tough if you
have that big of a hole in your game you
know
but that being said that [ __ ]
can wrestle he looked really good man
but i see i don't think that holds up
against like a mock jeff
at all not a chance if you're a blue
belt
be tough
speaking of blue belts these guys aren't
blue belts they're white belts but uh
two of the thick boy staff
tall george and big george that's how i
separate them so big george is the
gentleman who lost nine thousand pounds
and uh he's lost a bunch of weight
and then uh tall george uh runs a bunch
of other stuff here
so
uh what they're doing
is they sign up my boy rich chow um
create this program called ulta training
so what they do is they pick a gym
and
they get world-class training so the the
trainer at this gym it's legacy mma in
burbank and both george is signed up um
yeah both georgia signed up it's a
20-week long program i think it ends in
december it's a 20-week long program
monday through friday 7 a.m to 8 p.m
five days a week monday through friday
20 weeks and they're taking people with
no
experience just you know common average
joe people or nobody has any fight
background and they train with the
highest level coaches and trainers in
the world with other like 10 or 12 other
people whoever signs up and at the end
of 20 weeks
you're gonna get and it's not just uh
jiu jitsu camp it's mma so you learn
wrestling boxing kickboxing muay thai
jiu jitsu you're in the whole gamut at
the end of 20 weeks if you want to no
pressure you can take a smoker against
another person that went through the
program
you know so i think both these guys are
going to choose to do the smoke at the
end of it
um but yeah they both signed up for it
they had their orientation on saturday
at legacy mma now alberto crane is the
coach there right now alberto crane
is a
jujitsu legend and for the georges i go
hey man orientation is tomorrow i think
10 a.m i said alberto crane is gonna be
there he's the guy who's doing this this
guy is a legend and i need you to do
your research i need you to just look
him up before you go in there this guy
is mma royalty you listen to everything
he says and whatever he says is bible
this guy is a freaking
legend
so that's one of their coaches dude and
these guys have no experience
and big george i'm sorry tall george was
like yeah i was like how was it he's
like it's cool man i got this giant
black guy mount for about an hour he
just didn't know how to get a mount yeah
so they were working on maui escapes
yeah first day i just giant dude on me
and turned
but yes that's who they're they're
getting to
learn from the best man
they do fight i want to corner both of
them that'd be fun
they're not going to fight each other
obviously right
i don't know how it's going to go down
dude
i don't think so no that'd be terrible
or that'd be cool yeah but also terrible
i'm sure they're gonna it'd be better if
they did it i prefer they did it we
don't need that around here
you know they don't need that out here
but they're they're they'll talk about
on cats after dark i think once they're
like week six i'll give them hair to
give us updates
um but i'm gonna go there check them out
help them out a little bit with their
grappling [ __ ] like that where is it
located at burbank oh burbank legacy mma
burbank
alberto crane literally
tip of the spear
jiu jitsu coach one of the best ever do
it man
legacy burbank that's where the boys are
going monday through friday so it's just
orientation on saturday but they start
uh officially i think july 18th
20 weeks i told him i said dude my
name's on the line on this rich child's
a good friend of mine he put all this
together if you're going to do it you've
got to commit you're not going to be
there in and out like you got to be in
they both seem in
so we'll see
if you regardless give me a good
learning experience for them yeah yeah
this will be so much fun
the class or the the whole thing they're
doing yeah things we say yeah
bringing a bunch of content uh georgian
you know do a vlog on it so
it'd be fun man
it seemed really fun yeah
congrats to them
well don't say congrats yeah i mean just
to take just even like take this
opportunity i'm gonna say congrats
they've only done an hour orientation
but i hear you i'd say way to go boys
way to go now we got some work to do
yeah feel me gotcha
let's take another little break fort
wayne i will see you
this thursday friday saturday that's
fort wayne indiana the next week i'm in
san diego we do have a shop and friends
next wednesday july 20th at the
hollywood improv but fort wayne indiana
come get some then san diego next
thursday friday saturday laugh factory
heart of san diego come get you some
tickets at thickboy.com
listen man for most of us learning a
second language in high school or
college wasn't exactly a high point
uh it was tough man listen i took french
for four years i can't speak el liquor
french i struggle with english we know
this guys and i talk for a living so
that's fun
now thanks to my friends at babel
i know exactly what my wife and kids are
talking [ __ ] to me about all the time
they don't think i know but i know
because i picked up spanish on babel
that's right babel the language learned
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions there's an addictively fun
and easy way to learn new languages
whether you'll be traveling abroad
connecting a deeper way with family
your boy here or you just have some free
time you want to learn new language
because you're awesome and you like
knowledge all right babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons that you
actually use in the real world
not like you know in high school and
college you're like what am i what's
happening here all right listen i told
you guys i did it because my family
talks trash about me behind my back at
the dinner table and now i know exactly
what they're talking about kind of it's
still a little dicey but i'm getting
there babel's 15-minute lessons make it
a perfect way to learn a new language on
the go do it in your car driving to work
learn new language what's up ditch the
jay-z music learn a language all right
other language learned apps use ai for
their lessons plans but not babel babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts who actually speak the
freaking language you're learning it's
like computer all right their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish your boy french italian and
german and a lot more there are so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcast games
videos stories even live classes plus it
comes with a 20 day money back
guaranteed start your new language
learning journey today with babel i'm
telling you guys it's easy 15 minutes a
day
you're gonna get
not fluent but pretty freaking good
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you get
additional three months for free that's
six months think how good you're gonna
be at deciphering what your family's
talking trash about you whether they're
french german chinese
spanish all right that's six months for
the price of just three just go to
babel.com use the promo code shop at
c-h-a-b that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code shop
all right what do we got jen
all right first one is jon jones and
francis sagano
once again going back up on social media
talking [ __ ] to each other yeah
well this is not so much [ __ ] this is
francis right here france said you're
definitely a hell of a champion but you
need to act like one it's okay to be
respectful for others achievements bro
it doesn't take anything out of your
success sit tight you get your turn
sincerely
the all caps king
and then jon jones
john said look at francis over there
defending elsa how cute i could take off
two more years and you guys work and you
guys work combined won't match what i've
done in the octagon
i'm really not impressed with you or
your boy i've seen you quit multiple
times your boy almost got flatlined last
time you faced alex both of you guys win
your next fight then i'll be impressed
until then keep keep the name out of
your mouth there's levels
hmm
yeah
i'm kind of stoked that they're talking
to each other yeah i'm into it man yeah
yeah
yeah i mean france did have a point
where he's like dude
we're fighting you're talking like
that's that that was the best comeback
in addition though john's just been
chilling right he's going to heavyweight
and because of his body of work can you
just talk this [ __ ] you know
fair point like the majority if not no
yeah the majority of fighters say that
he is oh dope yeah
it's i mean he's the greatest we've ever
had man yeah i can't wait for him to
have him or stipe oh my god
i hope i'm not on the road
um check this out
so
tommy fury's father
i think was speaking to dizone and said
that he wasn't really even training he
should be trying to i'll show you this
for her
so his dad this is tommy fury's dad said
tommy wasn't exactly in training he'd
only had about 10 days because he'd been
on holiday
uh which means
vacation she's doing nothing yep in
england it's been a holiday and was and
it was a surprising thing for him
i was a way out of it doing these tours
and being busy elsewhere so i never got
the chance to look at it properly
when i paid attention i was the whole
thing wasn't right anyway but i said
okay it is what it is you want to go
over there and box him do it you're
experienced enough now it's a 50 50
platform i know you could be fitter
you're overweight but it's entirely up
to yourself because i'm busy i can't do
it so he said okay then i'll do my own
thing i'll go fight him anyways because
i can beat him
and so basically
he's saying well this is what jake paul
did afterwards
after hearing this feel like tommy fear
is my better looking younger brother and
we have the same haircut
um
so jake paul said i should sue this fool
owned that exposed white pulled out the
second time
yeah it is weird also john furrier what
are you doing
dude i don't know can you imagine having
a dad that just [ __ ] creates
headlines and [ __ ] he talks so much
smack yeah it's just like now you [ __ ]
your son over like yo he's out of shape
he's never gonna do it you know what
what i'd like dad what the [ __ ] like
well i'm just telling the truth i'm like
you know you [ __ ] me dude
none of this was serious you can tell
tommy fury wasn't serious yeah clearly
that's a i assume that's a voodoo donut
that looks like the thick boy donut yeah
it does yeah
i believe
yeah jake paul has a tough fight now oh
yeah so that's the ice fighting he was
an old my previous sparring partner
haseem homme junior i guess his dad was
like a really good boxer his debbie
likes lewis there you go what do you
mean you guess
i had like 50 fights dude he has debbie
lennox lewis
um
yeah it's a you know i we we did a shop
show hot take on it last weekend you
think boy chow now i break it down but
uh ramen you know raham ramen ramen
ramen sans ramen junior is no punk you
know he's had i think 12 fights he's
12-1 he's had over 100 amateur fights
so for those of you who were like oh
jake's not a real boxer until he fights
a boxer well this is it yeah
i mean
ramen compared to [ __ ] tommy fury is
night and day night and day the guy has
a ton of experience and short notice too
short notice like i'm not and listen
logan paul and his managers were like i
don't think this is great but jake wants
to do it you know and they know each
other a little bit because they sparred
and there's the video of them you know
talking [ __ ] to each other so
you know i don't like it i know it's at
cruiserweight but you know rum is uh
naturally a heavyweight
for jake i don't see the upside on it
short nose fight not a huge name unless
you're super hardcore think about you're
like i think his dad's a famous fight
you know what i'm saying and you're i
mean you're on this show like you're
around fighting i know i'm just but
that's what i'm saying like it's such a
big risk because
like he's not a well-known guy so i'd
imagine the pay-per-view number's
probably not going to be great tougher
fight mass square garden like it's not a
huge upside to it besides looking for
this validation from the fight community
which
hey tell you jake if you knock this dude
out in three seconds you're still not
getting it and that's the way the
business goes you know
you're still getting people like oh
let's see do that to canelo
what
the [ __ ]
until he beats canelo i'm just not a fan
mm-hmm you know i hear you but this i'm
telling you if you were to beat robin jr
this is
legit right as legit as it gets dude yep
he has a hundred amateur fights grew up
boxing
i heard his daddy wasn't around okay but
he's constantly unboxing him yeah his
dad was country on boxing okay he could
do both but whatever i don't know the
details
but um
he did uh he was oh there's never been a
father-son world champion so that's my
goal
i i just yeah i i don't like it for jake
i was talking with him last week about
it i was like dude god bless you get
some [ __ ] cajones my man but this is
dicey
he's like you'll see oh [ __ ] all right
i'll be watching
all right what else you got shout out to
jake paul yeah he and then i guess ramon
ramen or however he pronounced the same
he said he was taking out easy on jake
paul when they were sparring but he
would kill him during this fight
yeah i don't get it yeah remember you
made a video about this
um yeah i try to be very i'm a fan of
chris brown
of course yeah but it's just what he did
was not cool obviously no so he does he
eventually apologized to israel
on that post here
and is he this video is hilarious i know
but good morning i'm the man you're just
some fan but you're right i'm sorry
brother it bugs me when people criticize
my work having never themselves risked
anything
it makes me a hypocrite to do exactly
that to you my bad keep on keeping on
champ that's cool yeah yeah all's good
i mean but for him it's like people are
just going to criticize movies right
it's all
and like perspective you're on top of
the world too man so
chris pratt yeah
yeah i mean yeah yeah it's acting too
you know
all right this is yuri and i don't think
he wants to fight next because you know
it's between jan and glover
for next fight
and i want to fight clover the next
fight
not because it will be
another big fight
but
just one reason
my performance was bad i told you guys
told you and it's off i will show you
why i'm the champion
clearly decisively
and i think glover deserve it
so here's the offer
get to it dude
i will show you
what's the offer
that's basically the author he's going
to give us like a date time he's like
here's the offer
yeah and then he pauses that's it
um yeah i mean whatever he wants to do
you know
um i think him and glover had off nights
and that's why such a good fight but
technically you know they both had bad
performances even though it's a finite
people love it it's one of the greatest
fights in
like heavyweight history you know
fundamentally and uh technically it was
a disaster and they all made a bunch of
mistakes fun to watch as a fan but
from a analytical standpoint it was not
their best outings
uh i i do think he he [ __ ] glover
yes if he's uh focused and tuning
[ __ ] clover up that's why he wants to
do it i bet
um i'm not mad at it i'd love glover get
another shot i love glover would you
rather see yon or glover though
yeah same i've seen that it's like all
right you won i know it was a [ __ ] show
but you still won let's move on but
um for him it's smart
and can he call the shots on that no not
as well that's what i'm just gonna say i
don't know
also is he in fiji where is that no is
that his hometown it's gotta be his
hometown is it because he went back home
holy [ __ ] we need to go there it looks
fantastic there's a rainforest where
he's from i think he's from [ __ ]
where's he from
same place
is czech republic czech republic looks
like that i need to get out of [ __ ]
l.a dude
yeah hofstra dc
i think it's czech republic yeah john it
looks fantastic there
it does look beautiful yeah i know the
the it doesn't work that way though
ufc doesn't work that way i mean maybe
if you're if you're john jones even then
it's dicey
they don't really let you pick your
fights you know yeah they might give
that give you like all right you could
like especially your connor right
different animal yours far cry from
conor but if you have that much power
you could be like
they might come to connor and go all
right dude uh we can do the chandler
thing or do you want to wait on diaz but
either way
you know this is what we're thinking in
this time frame which would you rather
go with
that's connor yeah
nobody else even gsb really gsp could
tell him when he wants to fight but not
who very rarely he could probably put
his input in but they're like yeah cool
you're getting this guy though very rare
you can pick your guys
all right so check this out
patreon's that
going to bkfc london to face carissa
sagala which i had to look her up
good fighter
okay go on the left yeah she's like one
two and one a record hell yeah dude yeah
i'm all over this fight
um that's the same card with uh michael
venom page and mike perry oh really yeah
oh we might have some interesting news
on that too
um love this
love page great fight for
this is why you guys should lay off a
page if you're gonna throw hate her way
she you know she's out in l.a shooting
movies she has all the movie offers she
has her only fans which she doesn't have
to do anything
paige financially is all set she doesn't
have to do [ __ ]
she just enjoys fighting
now think about this straight up dime
piece i'm gonna [ __ ] what you're
attracted to that is a good looking
creature that is a fantastic looking
human being
she chooses
not to fight in ufc not bellator all
that she chooses to fight in
beer
knuckle fighting championship now for
the money she set not for the fame she
sat now for the instagram followers she
sat that new picture okay
she chooses this just because
she loves to fight
you gotta give her credit man she'd have
to do [ __ ] dude
nothing
okay
it's a little distracting so it's pretty
cool so um yeah shooting a movie and
then she can get ready for this it's
crazy dude
so dope yeah
very dope
so when i just clicked on this that dude
that this guy
dr wu i know
i know what about doctor who just posted
this those aren't crocs dude they look
like crocs don't they yeah those are
called clogs
see how those are leather yeah
they're not pop
styrofoam
clogs i get to see those are
birkenstocks burger socks would you use
dr wu would you sport those in
or is it too similar to
ah crocs a nice leather
and i also like that vibe i also love dr
wilson yeah oh you know who i met uh
yesterday at the car show uh ben baller
oh sweet is he korean he's crying i
think he's like i don't want to say
anything but
he looks korean he's crying bro he
pulled up
he's so rich man i don't realize how
rich he is oh yeah dude he pulled up i'm
trying to think what cars have been
there ah this might be the most
expensive they've had there he pulled up
in a mclaren uh
uh
god what [ __ ] mclaren did he pull up
in
um
oh my god why am i forgetting the the
mclaren
it has glass doors it's that one on the
right there this one yes
a sienna
a santa oh damn that's his car that
looks crazy dude
i think you can get him for sticker if
you're lucky around 8 20. they're going
for like 1.2 right now damn
has like clear doors on the thing is
filthy dude filthy
he's a big car guy that looks pretty
sick the only thing i don't like about
mclaren's is they're smaller right they
just look small i don't fit in any of
them they talk everyone's like oh you
try the lt but i just i love mclarens
it's just not i've been certain ferraris
uh
lambo suv is great for the best suv i've
ever owned by far
car wise i don't fit anything some
people think some aventadors i can fit
in but outside that lambos i'm not
comfortable in at all the horace i look
like wreck-it ralph if i'm in it um
mclaren's are tight too yeah they look
like they're probably porsche fit fit
like a glove that's another thing i
thought porsches were
smaller but i guess they're roomy
and guess what ferrari was like oh big
man you like them we make double x seats
now like extra large seats for big guys
nice
i like to think they did that for me but
i don't think so would you ever be
interested in like a rules you know the
the suv roles
um i uh we rented one in in dallas and i
wasn't impressed and they're also a
nightmare chin for maintenance i could
imagine dude they're a nightmare i like
the way they look
nothing screams
[ __ ] more than pulling up in a royals
i i i don't know what it is i love the
way they look
they look dope uh there's a black series
with interior's dope but for how much
they cost
the interiors are not like my yours
destroys those interiors destroys them
handling everything destroys them
yeah then they're they're dicey man the
finances on those things are dicey
they look dope though but ah they do
look dope girl i'm i if i'm gonna go
like that and i'm getting i'm getting
your boys getting older your boys
getting older let's not lie to each
other you're boys getting older if i'm
gonna go with a four-door sedan
it's i'm bently all the way it's british
the british jeans in me i'm getting
british green tan leather
kids gonna put [ __ ]
gummy bears all over the [ __ ] seats
once i get to dad mobile that's what
it's gonna be
man top three cars i've ever owned i
[ __ ] love that they still ran out of
warranty though i took it in like this
how much is for an oil change i was like
wait what
oh my god i gotta get out of here
the interior's like like nothing else
man my favorite
all right so felice herrick just retired
and now she joined bks bkfc man they
have a hardcore fan base but it is
the pro the promo promotion of it's
getting better the [ __ ] fighters are
getting better dude mike perry and uh
microphone and page is fire that's super
cool vanzant fire
police hearing
it's
fire
good picture of her yeah
i think she's got one of those only fan
stuff things too
she's another one i gotta make more
doing only fans that again you gotta
respect the hustle dude because she's
like yeah i could just keep doing only
fans or i can go into bare knuckle
fighting
it's insane here not cool
it's insane
all right let's take a look at this
one's not a huge deal but just nate nate
diaz posted this july 30th would be a
nice to departure date
which i don't really get what that is
other than it's a ufc 277 i think july
thursday
they wouldn't announce it yet
you know what i'm saying like that if
they're if nate's gonna fight during
gives a two-month notice so they can
milk it for everything especially with
this last one yeah it ain't happening
that's july thurs uh we have a fight
campaign for that
solid you know main card
most excited for anthony smith
and uh
magamed top five friend smith he's the
underdog
going for anthony smith there
um
derrick lewis hometown boys in houston
brian moreno and kaiker of france is a
great yeah that's a fun one going for
brandon they're
obviously julian pena amanda nunes i
don't see penny get it done man yeah you
know i think it's her time
drew dober doing the goddamn thing love
to watch him fight
yeah it's it's solid card not as good as
the last one but listen last one
we're all jacking off to
and it was not fun let's be honest it
was not a great card um
so we have fight command for that july
30th for sure are we doing this weekend
or no are we doing what fight companion
for the fight night yeah
because it's ortega and yeah no i wish
i'm in fort wayne indiana i thought
maybe you would have like your homies
coming like no no three in a month jesus
christ just yeah i'm with you i would
have told you all right cool
this is a pretty crazy this guy got head
kicked and before the ref came in he
waved it off himself and it's a crazy
check this out
[Applause]
orbital bone or something like that you
know like you know you're like oh hell
no it's so loud i'm making 300
you know
when you're doing those other fights
you're like dude i'm making 300 you're
going through in your head i'm like i'm
the [ __ ] out of here
good for him
i can't believe this happened
again so big priscilla was in another
boxing match another mma but boxing
match and what do you think happened how
are you smacked out how's he keep
getting fights
that action
he just looks slow
and his head is just there for
everything
[Music]
and you can't miss either you can't miss
he's just taking it then oh my god dude
[Applause]
oh my god man yeah he needs to stop
immediately
the the thing about him when i you know
how much he lost in a round now ten
straight probably
bigfoot suffered his 10th straight loss
in combat sports dude and a lot of those
are [ __ ] knockouts
i just don't get it the problem too with
bigfoot is he's the nicest dude so you
got to figure
i would assume these joints because it
needs money yeah it's such a shame
because he has kids man he's such a good
[ __ ] person
it's such a shame to watch yeah his head
is so big the biggest head you've ever
seen it's my it's marks and chins
combined dude mark's length
mark slammed my chin's width
you guys know i agree mark you know you
have a long head yeah
yeah yeah you have long head and you
have a wide head we know this yeah so
you put them together and you get
bigfoot's hat
you get big you get bigfoot silver's
head yeah so head movement not our thing
it's not happening because you move one
foot it's doesn't matter dude
part of your head's still there so head
movement's not your thing
so it's just a disaster yeah and you
just like like [ __ ] dc said he goes
dude when i was like well i was talking
about after the these uh after he he
beat [ __ ] uh bigfoot in his prime in
uh strikeforce he goes i couldn't miss i
could have missed it i thought one two i
thought here and here you can't miss
his head's too big dude it was too easy
like that ain't good if you're bigfoot
tons of those punches were landing hard
too we just wouldn't go down i mean they
tend in a row
even in even russia right now i was like
okay how are we saving this thing
and someone's like it's russia he's like
no i know but general
how does someone just like i don't want
to keep doing this and at what point did
like that guy beat him right this
[ __ ] uh exactly
beat him
okay
you're the tenth guy in a row to do it
is it really a cap in your feather at
this point
like at this point it's like you know
it's terrible dude yeah
this is the tommy fury bigfoot silva
no jake paul bigfoot silva
no no thank you
i don't see it either dude it seems like
one of the stories where we were going
to read about him something
bad happening you know oh yeah yeah that
sucks
uh this is a weird one too remember that
youtuber guy that we mentioned before we
talked about the show before he yeah you
can't fight but then he did fight an mma
guy uh ufc ex-ufc guy did okay bro
here's the thing
manny you know this is just all [ __ ]
they're they're not really gonna punch
each other but the
the the korean youtuber dku
he is the rudy of fighting
like he's never done more with one thing
than anybody else in the history of
fighting this guy creates these videos
these hype videos just like rudy got a
sack against the fourth string
quarterback they came out the field
which was a joke uh joe montana tells it
he was on the team gonna listen to joe
montano over rudy but uh this guy's
basically rudy because
dude you're making chicken [ __ ] into
chicken soup he's my entire career like
this dude
dku is fighting manny pacquiao dude
he got started off [ __ ] youtube
videos
and he's announcing that he's fighting
manny
[ __ ] pacquiao
nuts
i'm not hating i mean why watch it
absolutely not
absolutely not his mma fight was
atrocious
but then dude think about that
i'm sure he's like a team like i do
everybody's sitting around like oh so we
did the mma man like they go well dk's
like i know i know i thought my [ __ ]
the [ __ ] death punch would work and
it didn't you know what is the guy's
blood type he has to be a blood type
that's why i didn't work what should we
do next they're like
i'm gonna box and fight with manny
pacquiao throw it out there
see if it ends they called manny's like
yes this is what the lord wants click
insane
it's insane
and why is his eye closed and one open
no that's manny's on the left no i know
that's what i'm saying why is one close
ball why are they both open
they have the same they have the same
nose looks like yeah it looks like
what a [ __ ] show
it just shows i mean man is just like i
mean government what's this youtuber
want like yeah apparently he's offering
you 10 million just to [ __ ]
get sweaty with him but he says no body
shots like yeah this can be a [ __ ]
night hey
boxing matching manny pacquiao
manny pacquiao best cavs of all time in
boxing oh yeah
challenge you to argue me on that
best with those thick
[ __ ] filipino casts those moana ish
polynesian [ __ ] filipino those thick
calves it's always so powerful dude
and he's like five foot
usually they would pop up would you type
in manny pacquiao calves
i'll just do legs oh never mind it
didn't go in oh you didn't do legs
dirt is that it yeah that these are it
best guys of all time look at that and
that's just walking fantastic yeah
so powerful
god he was fun when he was in his
primary my god
i had manny pacquiao shorts
just a big white guy from denver wearing
manny pacquiao shorts how big of a deal
he was
um
i don't know if we talked about this or
there's a thick boy post but so darren
till was supposed to fight jack manson
but he has an undisclosed injury
so now chris curtis is going to replace
him chris curtis no punk no it's a tough
fight for jack hermeson yeah
uh yeah tough fight short notice very
tough fight for jack
um
also this alexander volkonovsky i think
he mentioned after the fight that he
broke his hand like after the second
round i think it was so he actually did
break his thumb and that's
right there that's what it looks like
welcome to the fraternity brother oh
yeah your thumb
they're gonna put some plates in that
and you're going to know when it's going
to rain or snow
[Music]
yeah the epic once so mine was a
compound fracture i'm like a guy named
johnny curse in washington dc fairfax
virginia to be fair but then i stayed in
washington dc and the bone i knocked
them out and i landed a punch because
the ref was it fast enough to get in
there so i landed punch and my bone
broke like
compound fracture
was that one of the worst pains you had
no it wasn't too bad i mean the next day
was [ __ ] terrible because i was like
yeah you'll be fine and then made me
walk washington dc and like look at the
lincoln memorial and i was all
lightheaded and my hands swelled up like
this
my brother's like i think we should take
him somewhere and the uh
promotion didn't cover the the surgery
or anything i had no money at the time
so here's the hustle so we got the
surgery because they have to take you in
so we get the surgery
and then you can negotiate the bill
you're like hey man i can't pay whatever
was six grand i have four hundred
dollars
i'm gonna pay a hundred bucks a month
and the hospital's like
all right
what are they gonna do
they're like all right i guess that
works i'm still painting
just kidding
um yeah i had like i stubbed my thumb
one time bad that was one of the worst
pains i've ever experienced because it
took forever to heal too
yeah my thumb i don't know why the worst
thing about this they put screws in it
and then um they and they have to have
two pins outside and they'd have to
tighten them up it's going every week to
tighten to
form the bone back together that hurt
yeah that's all that that hurts down to
your core
no surgery by far the worst thing i'm
done
this was surprising to me so this is the
salaries for it's the second half of
2022 pfl regular season so anthony
pettis got paid 750k
has he had a win in the bfl yet i don't
think i mean he's obviously a huge name
former ufc
dude when he was on the wheeze box and i
forget who he fought we're in the same
car together but he was i've me and him
found the same card maybe it was a trash
brown card medium found the same card
when he was coming off the wheaties box
bro he was so fake i remembered so
[ __ ] big
uh yeah so you beat miles price but dude
he's
one in three yeah in bfl they're all
we need to get some wins my man anybody
like freaking 750 that's even before the
million dollar prize thing so he's just
getting paid that but in order to get
the mailing you have to win the
tournament yeah so he's not stitching
that yeah
that's more than you're making yeah
yeah
so i mean you lose three in a row and
you're getting paid a lot of money
they're gonna cut you 100
uh i figured uh
kyla harrison would be the highest paid
fighter in that i mean she's
maybe just two hardcores but i mean
never lost face of the pfl
obviously no matter even if pettis went
over there undefeated knocked about in
one second jumping off the cage he's
still a ufc guy
barna did too much work in the fc wc the
ufc so
um i get why they pay him high because
there's notoriety but i assume i figured
kyla harrison's their highest paid
yeah they probably had an older contract
they're not the biggest draw though
because
she has nobody to fight you know
we don't know any of your opponent's
names no they'll be like uh her next
opponent 155 pounds [ __ ] her name up
at starbucks started talking [ __ ]
you know it's like they're just
searching for opponents yeah
oh i love this fight if dude i think it
made it into the cut on food truck
diaries but when belial muhammad was on
food truck
you know he was talking about uh hamzat
he's talking about title shot he was
talking about
nate diaz and i said dude i know it's
not
as sexy as those fights i'd love to see
fight sean
uh brady really i was like i'd love you
for sean bray i'm a huge sean brady fan
those philly boys are doing something i
know it's the water onto the [ __ ]
cheese steaks always because they're
wearing kicks from suplex philly i don't
know what it is them boys are on fire
and sean brady is the captain of that
team and he is a problem
i just think it's a fun fight for
muhammad now
for him to get to where he wants to go
probably i i would just and even
belittle said this he was like yeah i'm
trying to get to you know these big boys
i'm like i know i know
uh i didn't think the ufc was gonna give
to him i would i bet if you asked
muhammad i should text him this is
probably the last fight he wanted it's a
tough aspect ah fight dude yeah tough
fight
sean brady's a savage
mohammed's at five you know and they're
like hey fight the number nine savage
who's undefeated it's like [ __ ] dude
give me one of these other guys he's
like sorry you're sean brady you know
i'm saying i'm telling you don't get a
pick unless you're a conor mcgregor you
really don't get to pick yeah
this proves it
here's another quick fight announcement
mckenzie dern versus that chinese girl
yanceon
that's good fight she's like yeah
definitely let's go mckenzie dern
and then i'll close it off with this for
the current events so this is a little
older but remember pedro munoz
uh with his eye injury
he had the statement and hopefully this
poke this right here
he's just close in his eye he's all
so basically him
and i closed what's this in uh
portuguese
i speak pork
[Music]
oh
hey guys sorry my fight didn't go is
playing up [ __ ]
the po
these kids man i know i'm telling you
these [ __ ] young kids are in their
crocs and their [ __ ] euphoria
watching they're vaping and dying their
hair and they're such savages on [ __ ]
social media you can't compete with
these [ __ ] young kids
he's just making fun of him one eye
cause like it's so easy to do
i yeah listen i don't think pedro wanted
out of the fight
you know knowing pedro's background he's
not that guy he's not gonna look for a
way out and he did very well in that
first round i think the judges have won
that first round
but it was a punch that [ __ ] desire
not the the poke no so that's where this
narrative comes from mm-hmm
that's [ __ ] hilarious
that's hilarious
uh you got a good one this weekend man
what's dope about this is your boys on
the road i'm back on uh tour this is the
first date uh for the summer tour the
trash panda summer tour is in fort wayne
indiana remember the fort wayne we're
again some recommendations we had a gym
what else we got uh mark we had a gym
we had some other recommendations
[Music]
yeah we definitely want those because
i've never been to fort wayne indiana i
i listen for when i can tell you where
it's at i
i just go i get on a plane hopefully i
land in the right spot if not i just
i'll do stand up in the park i don't
know but um in fort wayne indiana new
club out there that's this thursday
friday saturday july 14th through the
16th it's fort wayne indiana what's dope
about this is that fight night is at 11
a.m pacific so daddy can watch it before
i go on stage i don't have to re-watch
it or miss anything and i'm ups i can't
can't believe they're doing that it's
not like it's in abu dhabi or england
it's in [ __ ] was it long island it's
in america ubs why are they doing this
that's long island okay yeah i don't
know why they're doing it but also brian
ortega rodriguez shouldn't be in like
phoenix or like texas
i don't i don't think there's a huge
mexican fan base in long island
who knows i'm sure just things lined up
you know i don't know how the ufc works
they're probably like [ __ ] it you guys
are here um
great main event phenomenal main event
brian ortega my boy t city known for
[ __ ] years
uh love brian
yair rodriguez savage absolute savage
they have uh a common a few common
opponents max holloway obviously
destroyed both of them can outclass both
of them um so that wasn't a great fight
for either one um but uh korean zombie
would be the one you would look at
mainly for the common opponent
now listen yara rodriguez
was lost that fight if that fight would
have went to the scorecards green zombie
won that fight but that was a second
left in the third round he threw a
spinning back elbow like from his knees
and landed it on [ __ ] uh korean
zombie ended up winning that fight
probably shouldn't won that fight he
really struggled with korean zombie
brian ortega absolutely destroyed
destroyed korean zombie
um
i've never been that high on yay i just
i have i think there's some mental
issues there as far as mental strength i
think he can be broke prior ortega
cannot be broke it's impossible to break
him he's as tough as they come
um
yaya raria's jiu jitsu is a little more
i would say flashy when it comes to
fundamentals and as far as
straight danger on the ground and
he doesn't need much but there's nobody
better than the featherweight division
of jiu jitsu than brian ortega as far as
finishing gets hold of your neck you
give him a slight opening this fight is
over i don't think guy rodriguez can
last five rounds with brian ortega
on the feet or on the ground i think
brian gets it done
via tko or rocks him then gets his neck
and chokes him out chokes him
unconscious i'm taking brian ortega via
finish under five rounds
bet on that money's on that i think
brian taylor gets it done he gets dicey
because brian ortega wins this one he's
not fighting volkanovsky again yes i
hope volkanovsky goes up to 55 uh in
order for him to become world champion
but remember too brian's the only guy
who's ever come close to beating
volkanovsky
that guillotine was in [ __ ] tight
dude
so
money's on brian i know i'm biased
because my boy i just i don't see how
jair beats him unless he does something
wild with a flying knee a jumping knee a
spinning back kick one of those wild
things sure as [ __ ] not going to submit
them
um
i don't think he's going to try and grab
him if he does try for a takedown his
neck is there at all times that's what
makes brian ortega so dangerous is the
way he views submissions is different
than everybody else and he sees it from
all angles i just don't think yeah has
the experience or the fundamentals to
avoid getting either knocked out or
finished by brian ortega via submission
for five rounds i don't see it happening
now if it's not a finish you got fight
of the year on your hands
because these boys both like to bang
they both have it in them so either way
we're getting a great fight finale fight
either in a stoppage or fight of the
year it ain't gonna be a boring decision
i guarantee you guarantee you great
fight finish or fight of the year
michelle watson has her hands full man
you know uh i feel like she's always a
little undersized for straw weight she
she came from invicta where uh you know
the 105 adam adam wait is more of her
thing it's a tough fight for very tough
fight for
uh your boy uh jin lang bash
jingling's back
uh schnell
[Music]
shane burgos and charles jordan is a
phenomenal fight
uh the rescheduled lauren murphy misha
tate taking mr tate obviously but my
favorite fight in the card is our boy
jack shore king of sting alumni versus
ricky simone i think jack shore gets it
done i'm a huge jack shore fan
same
tough fight though but yeah very tough
fight for him this reason is the main
event on the prelims on espn but uh this
on abc
what if it's on early sunday abc's like
dude we got
we got golf in the afternoon can you
guys just do it early
you know she's like yeah i guess
maybe she's like wait uh you put two
mexicans on long island yes he's like
hey we're trying our best here here
would be awesome la if they did here
there's a million places anywhere but
long island yeah
uh but either way good great fight can't
wait for it phenomenal fight when this
got announced people are foaming at the
dick great fight by ortega gets done via
under five rounds
bet that daddy is that it that's it
that's at 11 a.m pacific on abc fort
wayne i will see this weekend i'm
excited to get back on tour man whole
new hour trash panda summer tours coming
to fort wayne indiana this thursday
friday saturday we have merch that you
can only buy in person there as well so
unless you come to the show you can't
get the merch it's merch just
for in person um some lady merch you
know how i do then next shop shaban
friends is at the hollywood improv uh
july 20th it's me and some very special
guests some [ __ ] monsters and it's
the late show it's 10 p.m show this time
because it's too hot out i i don't like
doing economy when it's bright outside
so i was like can i get the late show
that i say less dude so the next job and
friends is july 20th that's next
wednesday then after that i'm back in
san diego san diego top five favorite
places do comedy that's why i shot my
first special at the spreckels theater
this time at the laugh factory uh
downtown the heart of san diego laugh
factory july 21st through the 23rd those
tickets are damn near sold out so get
your tickets right now for san diego
that is next week july 21st through the
23rd we have some special guests on that
show as well and then august 4th through
the 6th is baltimore
and then just announces chicago
it's at the den theater friday night
august 26 in chicago downtown chicago
den theater one show only i think it's 7
30 show one show only in chicago at the
den theater because the next day is the
tough mudder on the 27th right outside
chicago i'm there for the thick mudder
and the thick mudder this time is um
it's me but they've put a limited uh
capacity on the signups because it's
getting too big i can't run with
everybody people get upset so they they
limited the amount of signups who can
run with me
uh so i think the promo code is team
brendan and you get temps off sign up
come run with your thick friend think
boy nation i'm calling you out right now
come on out run the thick mudder with me
on august 27th go to toughmudder.com
it's the 26th i think it's 10 a.m race
they should have the thick uh thick
mudder up there already promo code is
team brendan
run the thick mutter with me come to the
comedy show on friday on the 26th
stickman on 27th
rain the whole think boys squad will be
out there mark's crazy ass will be there
everybody will be there come on out
thick mudder is august 27th in chicago
then after that september gets dicey
september's appleton wisconsin houston
texas boston boston my favorite city
that's why my son's name after it holler
tickets at thickboy.com or f-a-t-k-z.com
before wayne indiana europe this
thursday friday saturday enjoy the
fights i'll be watching from the airbnb
in fort wayne if i make it i love you
guys stay safe
be cool see you next time
you